What is the benefit of doing a sauna if I'm not really sweating?
Well, it's not uncommon that people will start doing a sauna and
Get frustrated because they're not sweating
But just keep it up. I've never had a person
continue to do a sauna try to stay there for 20
plus minutes and have it then not end up getting a breakthrough where they start
sweating. I know there are people it has to do
logically
with your
With the sweat glands themselves
So if you keep up doing a sauna and
You will end up getting a breakthrough and you will end up sweating the whole idea of doing a sauna is really too sweat
So this person must have heard me say that before and it's like, well, what am I doing a sauna for?
Where are we there from 15 minutes and I'm not even sweating?
Well continue to do it. There's there are other benefits of the heat as well
But you really want to start sweating and you will end up getting a breakthrough and you will start sweating
It can take a long time for some people to really have that experience
The majority of people start sweating in about two minutes at a sauna
But that's not you just keep it up keep doing it on a regular basis. So you will so that won't be an issue